>> Greg: AMERICA'S TOP
DR. FACING NEW CALLS TO RESIGN
AFTER BEING ACCUSED OF LYING TO
CONGRESS.
DR. FAUCI HAS REPEATEDLY DENIED
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF HEALTH
FUNDED CONTROVERSIAL RESEARCH
THAT COULD HAVE CONTRIBUTED.
A SENATOR RAND PAUL HAS BEEN
SOUNDING THE ALARM AND WANTS
DR. FAUCI GONE.
>> YOU SHOULD BE FIRED.
ABSOLUTELY.
THE THING IS JUST FOR LACK OF
JUDGMENT IF ANYTHING ELSE, HE'S
PROBABLY NEVER GOING TO ADMIT
THAT HE LIED WHEN HE WILL
CONTINUE TO DISSEMBLE AND WORK
AROUND THE TRUTH AND MASSAGE THE
TRUTH.
YOU MAKE DR. FAUCI STILL CLAIMS
HE DID NOTHING WRONG.
>> I OBVIOUSLY TOTALLY DISAGREE,
HE IS ABSOLUTELY INCORRECT.
NEITHER I NOR DR. FRANCIS
COLLINS LIED OR MISLED ABOUT
WHAT WE'VE DONE.
I'M WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT GAIN
OF FUNCTION, THEY MAKE THAT
IMPLICATION WHICH IS
UNCONSCIONABLE TO DO TO SAVE MAY
BE THAT LED TO SARS-COV-2 YOU
CAN ASK ANY PERSON OF GOOD FAITH
WAS A VIROLOGIST AND THEY WILL
TELL YOU ABSOLUTELY CLEARLY THAT
WOULD BE MOLECULARLY IMPOSSIBLE.
IN >> Greg: MOLECULARLY
IMPOSSIBLE.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS MY NICKNAME
GROWING UP.
>> Greg: IF YOU CALL FOR
DR. FAUCI TO BE FIRED, IT'S LESS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN AND YOU SAW
THAT WITH THE WALL AND REMAIN IN
MEXICO.
HE'S JUST GOING TO SAY NO HE'S
NOT.
>> Jesse: YOU MIGHT NOT BE
ABOVE FIRED, BUT HE MIGHT RETIRE
BECAUSE OF THE DOG THING SO EMMA
COMES INTO BREAKFAST AND SAYS
DID YOU SEE DR. FAUCI KILL DOGS
AND I HAD TO LOOK AROUND AND
YES, HE GAVE THEM TO DO THESE
DEADLY EXPERIMENTS ON DOGS.
IT WOULD RIP THEIR VOCAL CORDS
OUT SO YOU COULDN'T HEAR THEM
SCREAMING AS THEY WERE INFECTED
WITH INSECTS AND THEN KILLED
THEM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY GAIN OF
FUNCTION, BUT IT'S THE DOGS THE
AMERICANS WILL BE MOST UPSET
ABOUT AND THAT MIGHT PUSH FAUCI
OVERBOARD.
HERE IS WHY WE HATE THE MEDIA.
RAND PAUL GETS UP AND ACCUSES
FAUCI AND FAUCI DENIES IT.
LOOK AT WHAT FAUCI SAID IN
LOOKING AT THE EVIDENCE TO TRY
TO FIND OUT THE TRUTH.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T WANT TO KNOW
THE TRUTH AND THAT'S WHY WE HATE
THEM.
HE GOT CAUGHT COLD AND THEN GOES
ON HIS SHOW AND SAYS HE DOESN'T
LIKE THE IMPLICATION THAT
SPECIFIC GRAND LEAD TO THAT
SPECIFIC VIRUS THAT WAS COVID-19
THAT KILLED 700,000 AMERICANS.
WE WERE SAYING YOU FUNDED GAIN
OF FUNCTION SLOPPY, RISKY
RESEARCH AT THIS NASTY LAB WHICH
LEAKED AND KILLED ALMOST
1 MILLION AMERICANS.
>> Greg: PERHAPS HE HAD A
DIFFERENT DEFINITION OF GAIN OF
FUNCTION SO THEY WERE TALKING OF
TWO DIFFERENT PAST EACH OTHER,
COULD THAT BE IT?
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY I CAN SEE
THIS.
>> I AM NOT A CLINICIAN OR
MEDICALLY TRAINED IN THIS REGARD
BUT I THINK ABOUT WHAT I'VE
HEARD OVER THE BODY OF WORK,
THERE IS COLLABORATION AMONGST
SCIENTIFIC LABS AROUND THE GLOBE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF
RESEARCH EFFORTS AS AMERICANS
PARTICULARLY IN CHINA, AS WELL
AS SOME OF THE THINGS WE HAVE
LOOKED AT HERE ALL IN AN EFFORT
TO TRY TO BRING ABOUT THE
SOLUTION AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
CURES.
I DON'T CONSIDER MYSELF A
SUPPORTER OF ANYBODY'S POLITICS
BECAUSE I BUY FROM THEIR
FRANCHISE.
I AM A BIG CHICK-FIL-A FAN.
I DON'T THINK WHEN I EAT A 12
PIECE NUGGETS IN A LARGE FRY
THAT SOMEHOW I'M CONTRIBUTE INTO
SOMEONE WHO HAS A DIFFERENT
POSITION THAN I DO ABOUT CHOICE.
I ALSO DON'T THINK IF I BUY AN
APPLE OR NIKE PRODUCT I AM
CONTRIBUTING TO CHINA'S ABILITY
TO BUILD UP THEIR MILITARY.
FAUCI AND RAND PAUL NEED TO LET
THEM IN A ROOM AND SHUT THE
DOOR, THE TWO OF THEM HAVE A
DEEP-SEATED PERSONAL ANIMOSITY
TOWARDS ONE ANOTHER AND YOU
CAN'T GET THE FACTS ANYMORE.
>> Jesse: WE GOT TO THEM AND
FAUCI LIED.
>> I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
WHOLE BODY OF WORK, I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT FAUCI OR THE NIH.
>> Jesse: WE DID LOOK AT THE
BODY OF WORK AND THERE IS
EVIDENCE THEY FUNDED GAIN OF
FUNCTION IN WUHAN.
>> EVERY PRESIDENT, EVERY
ADMINISTRATION OF THE LAST 50
YEARS WOULD HAVE BEEN GUILTY OF
THIS.
>> Jesse: GAIN OF FUNCTION
STARTED RECENTLY, IT IS RISKY, A
LOT OF SCIENTISTS DON'T LIKE IT
BECAUSE IT IS RISKY FOR NOW WE
DON'T KNOW IF IT CAUSES PANDEMIC
BUT WHAT WE ARE SAYING AS IT WAS
RISKY RESEARCH HAD A SLOPPY LAB
THAT ENDED UP LEAKING AND
KILLING US.
>> WHAT I'M CONCERNED IS THERE
WAS SOMETHING INTENTIONAL.
>> Jesse: YOU THINK THE
CHINESE INTENTIONALLY LEAKED
THIS VIRUS?
I'M GLAD YOU SAID AND I DIDN'T
SAY IT.
>> THE REASON I SAY THIS, THEY
WON'T LET US IN AND THE
PRESUMPTION HAS TO BE IF THEY
WON'T LET US IN TO INVESTIGATE,
YOU END UP THINKING THE WORSE.
I COULD BE WRONG, BUT THAT IS
WHY WE ARRIVED AT THAT POINT.
I SAY AND I DECLARE IT.
>> Dana: EBELING THAT
SENATOR PAUL AND DR. FAUCI BOTH
WANT THE BEST FOR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND SO I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE
ARGUMENTATION HAS GOTTEN TO BE
LIKE A POLITICAL LIGHTNING ROD
TO MOVE PEOPLE ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER FROM A VERY GOOD TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
WOULD LOVE MORE FOCUS ON THE
CHINA PIECE AND WHATEVER WAS
HAPPENING IN THE LAB, IT COULD
HAPPEN AGAIN AND WE HAVE TO JUST
PRESUME THAT THEY DID.
SOMEBODY CALLED ANOTHER
BIPARTISAN, I DON'T THINK WE
NEED ONE.
>> Greg: I'M TIRED OF THEM.
>> Dagen: WE NEVER GET ANY
ANSWERS.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IT'S CLOSE OUT
THE ALTAR AT THIS POINT, HE HAS
PASSED HIS YOUTHFULNESS IF HE
EVER HAD ANY.
UNLESS HE WAS THERE, AND HAROLD
ESSENTIALLY WAS SAYING
AMERICAN DOLLARS WENT TO CREATE
A BIO WEAPON.
THAT WAS UNLEASHED ON THE WORLD
AND KILLED 5 MILLION.
>> I DID NOT SAY THAT.
>> Dagen: THAT'S THE
IMPLICATION.
>> THAT IS NOT MY IMPLICATION
BUT YOUR INTERPRETATION COME I
WANT TO BE CLEAR.
>> Dagen: THESE ORGANIZATIONS
WE NEED TO RELY ON HAVE BECOME
SOLIDIFIED UNDER JOE BIDEN WITH
FAUCI'S ORGANIZATION, THE CDC
WITH CHILDREN VACCINATED STILL
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK, THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
WHERE W